we live on the continent of elios
four realms surrounding a holy land at
its center
a thousand years ago our lands endured a
vicious war with the fel dragon
we called upon heroes from other worlds
to aid us heroes known as emblems
with them the warriors of our nations
fought as one
in the end we were victorious in
defeating and imprisoning the fel dragon
in the years since our world has been
safe
but now
i sense a resurrection the binding
weakens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're awake oh you're really awake yeah
a thousand years that's how long i've
been asleep
what are those horrible things
if i may
you are a divine dragon
a member of a royal family of dragons
revered as deities the war
the fel dragon
i feel
[Music]
[Music]
leave it to me
it is rather quiet i know
but it will liven up as we gain allies
the time has come
now as one emblem
engage
[Music]
one striker excited all
please grant me your strength
[Music]
she asked me to gather all of the rings
and bring peace back to elios
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ah
[Music]
introducing a brand new game in the
octopath traveler series
eight new travelers embark on a journey
through the land of celestia with that
we could realize a world without
conflict
without bloodshed
i'm going to become a star
and bring smiles to people's faces just
like mama i'm hitting the road i'll be
back once i eliminate that devil called
poverty from the world the man who took
everything from me shall die by my hand
not again not this stench the stench of
blood
doubt is what i do
leave the hunting to me you'll have all
the tasty meat you want
i need to rediscover who i am
explore a wide world set in a bustling
era
each traveler's path action differs
between day and night
our lord knows well the ways of the
world what will happen when their paths
intertwine what's that big realm
[Applause]
and what adventures await them in this
new world
[Music]
the eight travelers each have their own
story to tell
where will their journeys lead them
and you
octopath traveler 2 launches on nintendo
switch february 24th 2023.
experience the events leading up to
final fantasy vii in this exhilarating
action rpg
zach fair is a young and ambitious
soldier operative aspiring to become a
hero
together with sephiroth and cloud he
investigates strange disappearances
within his elite unit
this remaster features enhanced hd
graphics an updated combat system and
new soundtrack arrangements
crisis core final fantasy 7 reunion
launches on nintendo switch december 13.
[Music]
uh
glory
[Applause]
oh
get ready for a devilishly good time
after 500 years umbra witch bayonetta
was revived in the present day in the
first bayonetta game she clashed with
angels to recover her lost memories
and in the second confronted demons to
save her best friend
now in this third installment she'll
fight to protect the world from the
sudden invasion of man-made bio-weapons
called homunculi
[Music]
she's gone from fighting for herself to
fighting for others
to fighting for the world
those who have overcome their past
histories with bayonetta to fight
alongside her include the journalist
luca
and another umbra witch jean
new ally viola also joins in on the
action
a hair raising
demon summoning
globetrotting adventure awaits
in bayonetta 3
launching a nintendo switch october 28th
pre-orders are available now on nintendo
eshop
after today's nintendo direct a new
trailer delving more into gameplay will
launch on our official youtube channel
there's a new hero who looks mechanical
introducing wave 2 of the xenoblade
chronicles 3 expansion pass for the
xenoblade chronicles 3 game
this is eno a new hero she appears to be
a mechanical
[Music]
complete her quest to have her join your
party
expanding your options for classes and
battle strategies
challenge battles will also be added
test your medal in consecutive battles
against tough enemies
defeat all enemy waves to earn rewards
challenge even stronger enemies to earn
valuable accessories and special outfits
[Music]
more hero and gameplay additions will
arrive in wave three
wave 2 of the xenoblade chronicles 3
expansion pass launches on nintendo
switch october 13th
[Music]